that there's a certain poetry to what
aaron rodgers
apparently orchestrated i don't think
what happened yesterday
was a mistake i don't think it was an
accident i don't think it was a
coincidence
the fuse was lit by the news that the
49ers
for some reason called the packers on
wednesday night
and offered the third overall pick and
more
to get aaron rodgers away from green bay
now i don't like it
makes them look even more wishy-washy
you gotta look decisive
why are you taking aaron rodgers for a
handful of years when you supposedly are
all in
for someone that you moved up to number
three for i don't like that part of it
but that came out as i'm sure aaron
rodgers
suspected it would once it came out what
happened
did they turn a hose on it and make it
go away no
it grew and grew and grew and the one
thing that really took it next level
wasn't anything we reported
it was shefty saying he's disgruntled
with the packers
and he's ready to move on that created
an avalanche of more reporting
to the point where i was told he
basically doesn't like anybody in that
front office
he wants out and it's 49ers
raiders broncos that's his wish list
that's where he wants to go
and that created an expectation that
maybe something would happen last night
but just because it didn't happen last
night doesn't mean it's not going to
happen
because we heard from brian goody koontz
we heard the old school football guy
attitude
basically you're under contract we're
not doing anything about it
we need to hear from aaron rodgers after
everything that happened yesterday
because yesterday was one of the most
significant days that i can remember
by way of an established quarterback who
led us to believe one thing
all of a sudden it just blew up in the
other direction well i mean
yeah i mean it's crazy you're right
established quarterback beyond that
i mean you know arguably the top three
player in football
i mean really i mean the mvp of football
that's where it's just
absolutely crazy it is hey come on
we all we all know aaron rodgers
disgruntled with the green bay packers i
mean we didn't need these reports so
like
that i mean we we spent a day earlier
this week talking about we think this
will be the last year with him there
it's this but but we thought he was in
for this year yes
we thought he was in for this year we
did it was jarring so what
but what's jarring about it is obviously
there's been
some issue with the contract and the
extension right
that's what i mean listen they've had
the head coach the gm
and the president all fly out to see him
all right so
with the contract situation i mean just
houses appears
yeah if rogers wants to stay in green
bay i bet he wants some sort of contract
that says
i'm here for the next three years like
at least
and there's nothing else we've been
saying since january i just want i don't
want to wear a groove in our back here
but we diagnosed this from the get i
know that he wants to be tied to green
bay
for multiple years he wants to take away
their year to year
power that they have over him he wants a
commitment he wants a contract that
forces them together right it basically
makes jordan love irrelevant yeah that's
what he wants right
yes he's going late i'm still awesome
i'm maybe the best player in the league
still
and i'd like to feel like hey i'm going
to be here
you guys are all in on me and we can go
all in on trying to win a super bowl
instead of like hey we're going all in
on getting to the playoffs and we're
just thinking about
more playoffs you know 10 years down the
road so
that's not cool and obviously he's not
getting the answers he wants with the
contract extension talk and everything
like that
so you know well i don't know the
specifics but just again at a base level
it seems like they're maybe giving them
like one year of security or something
like that and he's going hey you know
what
screw you i don't want that if it's
going to be one year
then i'm going to call the shots and i
don't want to be here i mean that's what
it seems at base level
and like mike i had this thrown out to
me this theory like because you you know
i hear your theory right like the
avalanche of stuff
i don't know was rogers behind it all of
those type of things
yes there is a there is a thought in the
nfl too
that green bay
just realized here in the last 48 hours
that like
oh it's it's over like he doesn't want
to be here
and you know i know some people that i
trust that feel like
green bay kind of let out the offer
about
from the 49ers and all that stuff to
kind of start a baseline conversation to
get this ball rolling
disagree okay i'm just facing what i've
learned based upon how
i spent a lot of time yesterday getting
to the bottom of how this got out it did
not get out from
from the packers the packers didn't want
this out they did not want this
yesterday
once it got out that's what sparked the
falling of the dominoes
that culminated in this sense that it's
inevitable he's going to be traded
even if the packers are going to
continue to refuse to trade him right
i compared it to michael corleone at the
end of the original
godfather settling all family business
during the baptism i mean
i think aaron rodgers hand-picked the
day that he was going to exact his
revenge on the packers and
the beauty of it is what it was the
first day of the draft
one year after the first day of the
draft when they threw him
neck deep into a vat of tequila by
taking jordan love
and surprising him and pissing him off
and he got his revenge exactly one year
later not
on a calendar standpoint but the start
of the next draft i think that
that that was calculated to some degree
look when you're going to be regarded as
one of the smartest players to ever put
on an nfl uniform people are going to
assume that a lot of things that happen
are calculated and i look at this too
when he told pat mcafee after he lit the
fuse
following the nfc championship game and
freaked everyone out
about his future by lumping himself in
to the group of people who may not be
back next year he
said ultimately my future is not
necessarily in my control
not necessarily in my control
keyword not necessarily in my control
he is now attempting
to control his future and my big
takeaway once it does settle on round
one chris and he wasn't traded obviously
we'd be talking about that if he was
the times come for him to tell us what
he wants yeah
i agree with that beating around the
bush being passive aggressive
making a vague comment forcing others to
try to interpret it and then getting
upset at people like me
for trying to interpret his vague and
ambiguous words that's over aaron
because we know you're capable of
telling people what you want
because you're telling everybody you
want jeopardy okay fine
we know that you can stop talking about
it now tell us what you want from your
football career it's okay
you're allowed to tell us what you want
you've earned that right quit playing
games
and tell everyone what you want that's
what i believe what he needs to do
sooner than later by the way he's going
to be at the kentucky derby tomorrow
hopefully somebody will ask him what he
wants and hopefully
he'll give us a straight answer not this
beating around the bush bullcrap that
we've been dealing with for how many
years now
yeah i i i hear you i hear you now
listen you know we could say all we want
and all that but i mean he's got every
bit
he's got every right to be disgruntled i
mean we know that i
i know i know i agree i know but don't
play games don't act like
you're not disgruntled but you make
these comments and then people say hey
maybe he's disgruntled he's like you're
a jerk for saying i'm disgruntled yeah
but you are disgruntled yeah why are you
playing games about it yeah
the time has come i agree if he really
wants to be traded and the time is now
again you know we i think we talked
about this two days ago public
perception is on his side
as good as it's ever been you know
everybody realizes he's kind of been
wrong there
he's never had like the great superstar
talent that some of the other
quarterbacks have had around them
it's always been on him he's the
mismatch that's it
he's never had you know gronk and
julian edelman with hernandez or a moss
with
a wes welker or a marvin harrison or
reggie wayne at dallas clark and edgar
and james
really when you talk about like the
great quarterbacks of all time
rogers has had the least amount of great
support around him out of any of them
any of them he's been done wrong it's
always on him
he outplayed the quarterback in the nfc
championship game this year
he made one mistake that was pass
interference
but they don't win why i don't because
they don't have the players to go they
don't go all in they don't go over the
edge to try to go all that way
again we've revisited this the bucks had
tristan worse and antoine winfield
they contributed their super bowl win
they were a big reason why they were
there and beat the packers and
everything like that
the packers had nobody from the draft
last year that contributed but
i do think you're right like it's it's
if he really wants to make this happen i
think it's time to play hardball
and stop you know playing games to a
degree
and and too much happened yesterday yeah
too much happened yesterday for him
to but well you know there's a lot of
reports out there well let me ask you
know there's a lot of stuff that people
say that isn't true
blah blah blah you got to take it head
on if you really want out
i don't think it's like that was like a
part of the master plan i don't
it's at least to me uh you tell me when
schefter reports it it's part of the
master plan
because he's only going to go with the
thing that he knows it's okay to go with
he's not going to go with the thing that
turns the world upside down and pisses
people off
because then he doesn't get his
five-minute heads up for the
transactions that are otherwise going to
be announced
he's not going to wade into a report
that people don't want
out there and so he got the green light
yes to go with this
right this is something somebody wanted
him to go with or he wouldn't have been
the one who reported it would have been
somebody else
that's why i'm saying we're at the point
of critical mass
and it's time for aaron rodgers because
they they can't blame me for this one
they can't blame the package can't blame
me for but i also checked he's the one
who put it out there
i'm just saying yeah this was not
accidental this was deliberate
the only thing i would just say is like
you know the jump off point first off
was the 49er trade stuff right
and obviously somebody told aaron
rodgers that that conversation was going
down because he called green bay and
said make the trade
right he wanted he wanted to go of
course he did what i mean go to the
49ers
back to his hometown and that team
of course he did i mean there's no way
the packers are going to trade aaron
rodgers to the 49ers there's no way
it's their biggest like one of their
biggest rivals in the conference right
now so that's not going to happen
but you know that's i i so what what i'm
saying is i think that was the jumping
off point and yeah then you're probably
right i don't know if it's somebody from
rogers camp
i don't know maybe is it somebody from
the 49ers that lets it out that he's
disgruntled and doesn't
trust the packers organization there's a
lot of different avenues but either way
yeah traces to rogers doesn't trace to
the 49ers
traces to rogers now hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports